the FAA is looking into another close
call at one of America's busiest
airports the pilots of an Aeromexico jet
approached the wrong one runway at San
Francisco International Airport on
Tuesday the plane was just hundreds of
feet from landing on top of another
airliner
Kris Van Cleave is following the
investigation Chris good morning good
morning this is the third time in six
months that something like this has
happened at SFO raising the obvious
question why does it keep happening in
San Francisco
this time the Aeromexico plane was less
than a mile away in descending when it
was told to go around Aeromexico flight
668 was on final approach to San
Francisco International Airport Tuesday
morning after its 5-hour trip from
Mexico City
[Applause]
despite the Aeromexico pilot confirming
the towers direction to land on runway
28 right the Boeing 737 lined up for the
parallel runway 28 left already occupied
by a Virgin America flight waiting to
take off flight tracking site
FlightAware lists the altitude for the
Aeromexico jet as being as low as six
hundred feet before controllers stepped
in the flight landed safely on its
second approach but this is the third
known apparent close call on a runway at
SFO since July when an Air Canada jet
attempted to land on a taxiway flying as
low as 59 feet for airliners were
waiting on that taxiway to take off and
in October and Air Canada flight did not
respond to repeated calls from the SFO
tower to abort its landing that crew
blamed a radio problem the NTSB is
investigating the July incident and now
the FAA will look into the one on
Tuesday the FAA has also changed rules
over the summer for nighttime landings
and staffing at the airport's control
tower
John kress thanks